es lo que más le preguntan al saber que
son trillizos
hemos apostado con la misma
hemos reunido a seis grupos de trillizos
somos
uno de los grupos es falso si el grupo
descubre quiénes son los mentirosos se
repartirán el premio
si los mentirosos sobreviven ganarán
todo el premio quien es el impostor el
impostor trillizos contra un impostor
fiesta de triste
pero por allá tenemos dos chicas y un
chico no es
pero eso no es justo para ellos
[Risas]
no somos fraternas
de la
diferencia sus padres cuando eran más
jóvenes nuestras madres nos
diferenciaban poniéndonos camisetas con
el nombre escrito en ellas
no todos los y un pequeño bulto en la
cabeza cuando se le cayó al crecer era
muy fácil decir sí
y me parece que somos mayores cuando te
vuelves un poco mayor de diferencia
por mucho tiempo
las cortes de cabello nuestros cortes de
cabello nos diferencia que acaban de
salir de una película de
ustedes dos se parecen mucho con
peinados diferentes pero te ves
diferente son idénticas ofrecer nada
les gustó de ustedes es algo que
decidió copiar me pueden decir quienes
habéis
si soy
yo soy
yo también soy y yo soy veis bien sé que
no queda mucho tiempo pero notado que
eres un poco más alta y también eres más
callada sí siempre
he estado hablando por ella nuestros
seguidores votan quién es el impostor
dejad su forma de ser es muy similar y
os es que bueno bien es hermanos
trillizos o solo hermanos quieres
diferenciarte tanto como pueda ser tan
parecido a tus hermanos es muy molesto
parecían nerviosas y no se os sanz gordi
griezmann hablar
[Música]
fue decepcionante pero no nos sorprende
haber sido eliminados mucha gente no nos
cree cuando decimos que somos trillizas
porque no somos idénticas y sabía que
eso sería algo a lo que tendríamos que
enfrentarnos al participar rodrigo una
pregunta quién empieza a todas las
peleas bien no nos entendemos pelear a
menudo creo que lo hacíamos cuando
éramos jóvenes pero ya lo hemos superado
somos muy unidas y los minutos de
exposición mientras hablaba miraba a las
otras dos y ellas se parecen mucho y no
sé si sea hermana de ellas cada vez que
estamos peleando es entre él y yo o él y
yo él es muy insistente si le dices que
padre no termina hasta que él también
encuentra que la broma ya perdió la
gracia
las que pelean son ellas el hombro como
mediadora nos incita en serio en serio
así que las instiga es lo que más le
preguntan al saber que son trillizos
el tamaño 18
y nos hemos ajustado con la misma chica
si la gente pregunta aquí los sabios
siempre les decimos averigua lo demás
por supuesto pero también la gente nos
pregunta si nos hemos acostado con la
misma chica al mismo tiempo lo que es
enfermizo nosotros no hemos viajado a
parís y así es es muy sutil chicos
piensen en la forma de la torre ya lo en
bera vieron no hay que explicar nada y a
ustedes se puede preguntar por el tamaño
no
son idénticos
así
que para hacer tres chicas de la misma
edad parece haber sido siempre muy
amistosas no parece que se peleará mucho
de todos los grupos aquí ustedes son las
más diferentes si estoy de acuerdo nos
dijeron que no se explicarían rápido
porque no les parece ni titular del
medio parece es una amiga que se siente
cuando están separados
eso cambiará
desde el vientre materno y la primera
vez que nos separamos fue al ir a la
utilidad me mudé no quiero ofender a mis
padres echaba de menos a mis hermanas
más que a nadie
estuvimos separadas 24 horas no no no
pudimos dormir todo al mismo tiempo
ustedes dos y son por completo
diferentes sí creo que ellos podrían ser
gemelos pero somos los villistas
fraternas somos largo terrenos por eso
pelean mucho como hermanas me peleo
mucho más que si lo dejamos atrás y
enseguida
es porque somos fraternos como es que
ustedes se llevan dominio creo que es
por el hecho de que mi hermana y yo
compartimos muchos amigos y es por eso
que compartimos mucho y con él no es tan
a menudo tenemos los mismos amigos y
asumo que acabas de decir que tienes los
enemigos como es para ti ser el chico en
este grupo contrario a ellos seguimos
siendo trillizos así que me siento
cercano a ellas como ellas a mí me llevo
mejor con ella no sé por qué pero me
lleva mejor con sus amigos y no también
con los amigos de hetero tiene hombres
dos amigos verdad tenemos algunos
amigos en la secundaria a todos nuestros
amigos asistían a la misma aunque todos
estábamos en aulas diferentes o lo mismo
escuela y la universidad que universidad
posibilidad los otros tres fueron
actions and tal vez son amigos que se
conocieron en la universidad hay vídeos
a que le llama la atención y es que te
es cuidado decir mamás dices misión y
más pero luego te diste cuenta y dijiste
mi mamá nuestra mamá podía diferenciar
porque se equivocó pero son solo mamá y
papá bueno claro eso lo mostraría pero
[Música]
como la otra hermano tenía el cabello
rizado y el chico tenía los extremos
parecía raro y la otra chica decidiera
alistarse el cabello eso nos lleva a
pensar que a lo mejor es una medio
hermana o tal vez una amiga
[Música]
adiós chicos
creo que todos son muy parecidos a tomar
una salida fácil los menos parecidos
levanten una mano del juego el impostor
sigue entre ustedes y si quieren seguir
jugando
a partir de ahora una vez que expulsen a
alguien que no sea el impostor se
reducirá el total del premio
tengo una gran 23 bien en telepatía
nosotros terminamos las frases de las
librerías a ver si les pasaba eso digan
su palabra favorita
321 origen no no dije nada
creo que hablamos por encima de la vida
es como cuando tienes un amigo y con
sólo mirarlo y decir sabes lo que pienso
y dices y lo sé si estamos en un evento
o en una fiesta en la que no estamos muy
cómodos todos sentimos el mismo impulso
de querer y
si debo decir esto creo que eres más
joven eres más para
la familia pero
sí
creo que los beer sí son muy parecidos
siento certeza de decir que son
trillizos desde que los vi ya que
nosotros sturniolo los varones y sus
hijos también son trillizos varones
podemos concordar con todo lo que decían
no sospechamos de los sturniolo ni de
los benavides
eso lo hacen a nosotros si fuese una
banda juvenil y estamos en el gimnasio y
los pondré incómodas a la cuenta de tres
voy a decir una pregunta bien en
responder al yen cómo se llama tu abuela
del lado materno
hay una perturbación en la fuerza
podemos saberlo bueno salvo
que todos nos parecemos pero al menos yo
no levante la mano cuando preguntaron si
el impostor seguía aquí no sé quién
parece sospechoso y seguramente
por ella
la personalidad
personalidad si son como dos personas
diferentes al crecer ella era una dulce
dama católica nos educó con severidad la
escuela es importante la religión es
importante y ahora nos dice muy bien
hagan lo que quieran
ella de policía bueno en mi padre el
malo sigue así y sigo pensando que es
menor y que estás en la secundaria puedo
ver tus zapatos son más también
parece que ustedes se prepararon para
venir aquí decidieron vestirse con los
mismos colores pero tú no estás usando
una camisa
es un pantalón que cubre tus zapatos
parece que
solo es más sus rasgos faciales son
mulos sturniolo y dices tienen forma de
sus ojos tienen formas diferentes quiero
saber de qué color era el cepillo de
dientes mientras crecían porque creo que
hay que tener un cepillo de dientes de
un color diferente para no usar el de
tus hermanos para los otros diferentes
cambiamos los colores que para ella es
el azul me gusta el rosa
azul rojo verde tener estos baños
diferentes yo compartía con mi hermano
mayor y ellos compartían un baño juntos
porque
somos cuatro y años así que dos y dos un
baño de un lado y otro del otro lado
creo que podría ser el hermano mayor
lo acepto el parece mayor pero ella
también lo hace mucho más
joven
estoy en la secundaria claro estás
usando unos tacones he ganado
a alguien que está con exceso de
confianza exceso de confianza en yebes
que me los unidos zapatos y sin visto
atacarme muy fuerte siento que querían
atacarnos a nosotros entre todos nos
ataca vamos con su dicción no estaba
coqueteando
buscaremos sus redes sociales
como se hicieron tan amigos eso era lo
que iba a presentar
[Música]
sabíamos que esto pasaría
sabían que pasaría porque es la verdad
creen que el impostor sigue entre
ustedes y si quieren seguir jugando
si las luces cambian a verde significa
que han expulsado el impostor y que han
ganado si las luces son rojas significa
que el impostor sigue entre ustedes y
pierden
sí
[Música]
yo sabía desde el principio los estudios
religiosos pueden las revelaciones dar
un paso adelante en
[Risas]
las
trillizas
hermanas pase lo que pase con tus otros
amigos sabes que siempre tienes a tus
hermanas y creo que eso es muy
importante para nosotras somos amigas de
cada una no sé qué haría nunca está solo
porque no quiero tener un solo hijo bien
dicho